hey guys Ryan right here dance happy
we're gonna watch the trailer for Dark
Souls 2 dark souls 2 dlc which comes out
next week as of the posting of this
video yes I don't know anything about it
except I heard it's a really hard game
mmm
like this hard Ryan down here you know
what I mean
you get it every time I'm around Dan
every time I'm around Dan get about her
I hang my hat from it no yes he has a
bowler hat 'triple bowler hat he pulls
it off well you were such a [ __ ]
wouldn't think like Oh dad could pull
off a bowler hat but he can really do it
mm-hmm this comes off and I have a
wonderful twirly twirly moustache
underneath mm-hmm
you see his [ __ ] too you gianormous when
have you seen that when I shower oh god
damn it you take showers with me too
yeah
I paint myself into the wall I would
explain where I put my little uh my Mars
soap I just gotta hang it on something
that randomly showed up wait how do you
hang your bars oh it's it's got a rope
it's go so hot rope oh so funny with
soap on a room I was like what you never
dropped off my go so--but okay I'm sorry
I can't see with the PEGI 16 namco miss
those guys they're still here they've
been around yeah
time to die
sounds like something I got
like the bad times
Wow cool
that looks cool looks like it would be a
thinker of a game dad it does require a
little bit of strategy yeah I ya know it
looks like hey they're not showing a lot
of strategy moments but I'm sure there's
a lot of strategy involved this is a
game that's been on the list of things
they need to do need to play I've been
going back and forth about starting a
Dark Souls 2 series a little scary it's
it's it's it's more rage gaming than it
is scary though it doesn't take a whole
lot to royally f up so originally dark
souls 2 wasn't supposed to have dlc ok
um tender loving care right sure but for
some reason they uh after they said like
we're not doing dlc they decided to do
DLC so uh I know I'm excited to see kind
of what they do with this but once again
like I still need to get through my
playthrough of Dark Souls 2 before mmm
I'm ready to start swearing some more
well I want to I want to play the game
you should you really should I bet you
there was a lot of people out there that
would love to see you die Oh some
sometimes I think it'd be fun you know
be fun too if I got head while playing
it you know there's those moments where
you're just like you're so mad that even
that can't you know really yeah it's
gonna be one of those words just like
[ __ ] get off me are gonna finish so
this game is harder than my dick yes
anyway guys if you're new to the channel
you can subscribe here and if you wanted
to subscribe to dance channel like
you've really consider it first please
do
he has a gaming channel here so year see
friends they help promote each other's
channels
he's on the channel yeah slender ik's
we lost program hahahahahahaha Linder
man shouting out time where I have to
sort through shoutouts and then go wait
a minute this guy asked for one a while
ago butters yo give me a shout-out
immediately because I've left like four
comments you might have ready but I
don't know
so give me one huh no I didn't give you
a shout-out butters I didn't I remember
name like butters but it's butter is
that butter but what are butters butters
from software
oh no not familiar Oh hamburgers one not
familiar with the was butters no oh
right we need to get you introduced the
butters [ __ ] girl bond friends good
learning about relationships and sex and
would explain a lot of my
characteristics mm-hmm
AOA Oh butters uh dude butters is
actually the name of Chris Rock's
character and lethal weapon for you guys
have something in common you guys has
something in common
you're Chris Rock using Chris Rock are
you Chris Rock you could be Chris Rock
but we don't you know we're doctors Rock
I highly doubt that
Chris Rock doesn't like trailers
reactions Joey keen what up Ryan I
didn't bunch of impressions in this
video and and he said I couldn't stop
laughing at your impressions at the end
of you trailer reaction video your
impressions are awesome what girl
wouldn't be turned on by movie acts and
impressions your legend Ryan listen
could I get a big shout-out from your
Irish deublin fan please and great Irish
impression as well can you say what's
the story in Irish that means hello in
Dublin cheers Ryan you're the man I read
that whole thing and I do that I read
the whole comment and you know what Joey
what's the story with yes son hey that
was leagues better than the last I tried
this new my friend Joey you're a good
son of a [ __ ] here yeah you make your
father proud
you're good Catholic my friend me you
pray to Lord Jesus every night your
unique and you make sure to do a damn
good job hmm every time you [ __ ] a girl
remember to pray for forgiveness for
fornication are you [ __ ] the girl
anyway go to a pub and get drunk are
they after me lucky charms don't we hope
it's little well that is just a great as
I understand
I had to I had to the stereotypes about
them are all true they all eat lucky
terms for breakfast in a bowl of beer
Dylan Wetzel what's up enjoy your movie
and trailer reaction great Ryan if
possible can I get a shout-out and could
you watch the blood-borne trailer just
uploaded it my friend oh oh
something Dylan Wetzel hahaha Wetzel
liked the pretzels what's up pretzels
can I have pretzels I hope you're that
person I hope here the inventor of
Wetzel's pretzels otherwise you need to
do more with your life because that name
is a legacy you got you might want the
fine you might be fighting your destiny
now yeah but eventually you're gonna
have to look yourself hard in the mirror
and say pretzels yeah that's really
where your heart is at we know this hmm
we know this also look in the mirror and
just go Dan Ryan alright but they're
also a bunch of dicks with big dicks
Oh word